Meredith Watson came forward shortly
after Vanessa Tyson made her accusations
in February she told us that she's very
sorry for not reporting her allegation
that fairfax raped her nearly 20 years
ago why do you feel guilty and had I had
the strength or the courage to say
something in 2004 Fox maintains that
both women are making false accusations
in a statement to CBS News the
Lieutenant Governor said this to us I am
able to hear the pain they have
expressed a pain I hope they are able to
resolve and heal however because I never
assaulted either dr. Tyson or Miss
Watson I know that my actions cannot be
the source of that pain now you can find
the lieutenant governor's full statement
on our website that CBS s Morning Calm
we are hoping that lieutenant governor
Fairfax will speak to us at some point
you will see more of our interview with
Meredith Watson tomorrow including why
she's asking for a public hearing as
opposed to an investigation and that she
is ready to testify under oath they both
say that they want to testify under oath
and they both women say about consensual
because Justin Fairfax who says that
these were consensual acts and both of
them say can't be consensual if they
felt that they were forced I said there
was a very distinct difference there and
there's an incredible amount of pain
there yes I all these years later than
all these years later that pain has
stuck with them about how they felt in
that moment and how it has affected them
now for decades you know and think about
the learning we have done there was a
period half a year ago where people said
you know these people are coming forward
after so many years why why are they
coming forward how can it really be so
real and we have now seen an example
after example of how it is as real as if
it happened yesterday right John mm-hmm